[Musica]
[Applauso]
e ieri tra due minuti ricordami di
mandarmi le risposte ok tutti i giorni
noi intervistiamo nel nostro assistente
vocale siri di google alexa vattelapesca
qualsiasi strumento lo intervistiamo per
chiedergli informazioni per chiedere una
risposta oppure loro più un modo un po
più subdolo si studiano i nostri
comportamenti e le nostre azioni i
nostri gusti per pian piano iniziare a
proporci loro dei contenuti piuttosto
che dei film della musica e quindi loro
iniziano a fare esperienza del nostro
modo di interagire con questi strumenti
e iniziano pian piano a suggerirci delle
strade o a condizionarci facciamo un po
di storia non aprendo così alla larga
questo per dire che una volta siri alexa
si chiamava tipo una marca poteva essere
la pizia la pizza era un oracolo era un
oracolo dove il re andavano davanti a
prostrarsi e le chiedevano informazioni
sul loro futuro sul loro passato
piuttosto che sul presente e anche la
pizia dava delle indicazioni dava delle
risposte leggeva ip dati interpretava e
dava delle visioni di futuro quindi meno
male l'intelligenza artificiale era già
un concerto anche nell'antica grecia
esisteva peccato però che a volte il
modello tipo dell'epoca la pizia poteva
commettere dei grandi errori piuttosto
che altri modelli di grandi oracoli e
quindi di diritto è un caso la fine
tragica di edipo in questo interessante
perché comunque anche oggi l'uomo si
pone nello stesso modo davanti a questi
strumenti
un po come fossero degli oracoli non si
interrogano intanto su troppo sui
processi che sono dietro alle risposte
che riceviamo
ma ci affacciamo come fossero dei nuovi
oracoli non si chiamano più la pizia ma
si chiamano machine learning e
intelligenza artificiale di learning
termini molto belli molto aulici che
sembrano affascinanti ma allo stesso
tempo potrebbero anche ottenere una
giusta distanza essere quasi voluti per
tenere una distanza tra gli specialisti
i nerd un'elite di persone che conosce
davvero cosa c'è dentro
le persone normali che ne usufruiscono e
grazie siri tanto sono arrivate le
risposte e le risposte alla domanda che
avrei voluto fare vuoi perché volevo
sapere alcune caratteristiche della
platea
cosa che succede spesso nate ed è
proprio iniziare facendo una domanda al
pubblico per ingaggiarlo maggiormente
ecco io non ho sull'uscita farla perché
avendo degli strumenti intelligenza
artificiale sapendo la presenza delle
persone oggi potevo sapere qualsiasi
cosa su di voi
a parte gli scherzi questo è
interessante per questa è una cosa che
si potrebbe fare con gli strumenti
giusti con più dati quindi sapere dei
dettagli che attualmente è forse siamo
una domanda stupida con delle risposte
tanto stupide però potrà portarci utili
nel corso della presentazione
questo per dire che oggi noi siamo
abituati a ricevere delle risposte ci
possono stupire che hanno quasi delle
intuizioni su come siamo fatti per che
raccolgono dei dati da questi
piattaforma qualsiasi modo e ci
interroghiamo forse poco allora vorrei
raccontarvi un po la storia del gruppo
con cui lavoro sono trenta ragazzi da
modena che con cui stiamo cercando di
rendere intelligenza artificiale un
qualcosa di tangibile alle persone aveva
individuato due aspetti che sono
l'intelligenza artificiale
sarebbe bene tenesse in considerazione
nel suo sviluppo
il primo aspetto è l'inclusività perché
l'intelligenza artificiale non è altro
che una black box
entrano dei dati vengono elaborati
escono dei dati più evoluti con delle
risposte molto più accurati rispetto a
quello che riusciremo a fare noi su
certi tipi di applicazioni però pochi si
interrogano cosa accade dentro non è
veramente un po mary poppins monde
estrae tutti gli elementi della sua
borsa io da bimbo mi ricordo rimanevo
affascinato e anche il bimbo del film va
a vedere cosa c'è dentro va a vedere
qual è il segreto
ecco oggi secondo noi dovrebbe essere
maggiormente inclusiva l'intelligenza
artificiale invece rimane il dominio di
pochi esperti di pochi tecnici e la
gente si pone sempre un po come una
sorta di oracolo
il secondo aspetto è la sensibilità
perché occorre rendere
sensibile ai sensi delle persone normali
tutto ciò che la sensibilità dei
matematici matematici sviluppano
matematiche tra nuvole di dati fanno
algoritmi predittivi modelli e così via
ecco tutti questi concetti vanno resi
tangibili e quindi bisogna trovare un
modo per ingaggiare le persone perché
possano comprendere come avviene questo
processo
ora un paio di minuti di matematica
giusto per tenere su attenzione facciamo
finta di avere un processo è un nostro
obiettivo da raggiungere un risultato
potrebbe essere anche una nostra
decisione nella nostra vita quotidiana
no abbiamo un processo mentale dobbiamo
prendere una decisione
abbiamo un processo industriale dobbiamo
massimizzare il rendimento
dobbiamo diminuire lo spreco controllare
l'energia e va plus
solitamente il nostro cervello come
funziona nostro cervello si concentra su
una correlazione principale o o poche
correlazioni principali la chiamo
correlazioni forti tendiamo a vedere
quel pensata anche quante volte mi
prenda delle scelte basandosi su delle
correlazioni forti ma la lunga le
correlazioni forti diventano un dato
autoreferenziale
è un dato autoreferenziale ci porta
l'informazione e non la conoscenza che
penso è una grande differenza un dato
autoreferenziale non mi permette di
poter fare delle analisi predittive di
fare delle decisioni ma io mi baso su
quelle tante volte nostre scelte che se
non lavorative e personali sono basate
su questi fattori dominanti oggi con
tutta l'esplosività di dati che ci sono
e con tutta l'attenzione che possiamo
prestare a questi nuovi processi si
possono raccogliere tanti dati che
gravitano intorno ai processi che ci
portano a prendere una decisione o che
dobbiamo controllare
ecco l'obiettivo nostro e farsi di
cercare di rendere il dato da
autoreferenziale è un dato relazionale è
un gioco di parole ma vuol dire passare
da avere un'informazione ad avere la
conoscenza perché solo nel momento in
cui io riesco a relazionare dei dati o
la conoscenza
questo tema pone tanti altri aspetti
importanti che non sta mai trattarli ma
sarà interessante indagare e
approfondire in futuro cioè la qualità
dei dati oppure chi dai dati e o di chi
sono i dati però questo è un altro tema
noi per cercare di passare da questa
filosofia che abbiamo raccontato ad alto
livello ma non renderla concreta e
mentre davanti le persone alle proprie
variabili che caratterizzano il loro
processo
abbiamo sviluppato uno strumento che
abbiamo chiamato quadro di dati come
funziona sulle ogni riga ogni colonna
rappresenta una variabile una variabile
che chiaramente e rappresenta la
fenomenologia del processo che vogliamo
studiare sull'asse del y andarsene l'ex
sono riportate le stesse variabili
abbiamo avuto l'idea di graphicar è in
rosso le correlazioni dirette una
variabile aumenta all'altro aumenta in
modo lineare in blu le correlazioni
inverse una variabile aumenta l'altra
diminuisce sempre in modo lineare
qui sono state grafica te le
correlazioni forti quelle che bene o
male la nostra mente riesce a vedere in
questo determinato processo in questo
caso è un processo industriale
sono i dati ma potrebbe essere anche un
processo transazionale oppure un
processo che ci riportano la nostra
scelta della nostra vita oppure quello
che ci fa sì che noi interroghiamo i
nostri assistenti virtuali
poi grazie una matematica che
sviluppiamo abbiamo estratto le
correlazioni deboli quelle che il nostro
cervello fa fatica a vedere a
concentrarsi più quindi questi quadrati
più piccoli rappresentano delle
correlazioni meno forte quella veramente
il nostro cervello in apparenza sembra
non considerare e in giallo
abbiamo grafica toe decorazioni non
lineare e quella ancora più complesse da
modellare una variabile aumenta e
l'altra fa delle s ecco questo questo
quadro di dati quando lo mettiamo
davanti a una persona che governo un
processo che riaprono la decisione è
molto interessante perché è il momento
in cui c'è un contatto tra il mondo
scientifico tra la sensibilità
matematica
e la sensibilità visiva dei sensi delle
persone una volta spiegato la leggenda
di questo quadro chiunque riesce a
interpretare e riesce a vedere le sue
variabili il suo sistema e lui stesso
viene ingaggiato è incluso in questo
processo matematico la complessità
rimane dietro chiaramente la complessità
non è di suo dominio ma la complessità
trova un punto di contatto per
ingaggiare l'uomo in questo e sviluppo
che sarà sempre più dirompente quindi
viene un po rotta quella borsa di mary
poppins e vengono svelati un po quali
sono le correlazioni che nella borsa di
mary poppins generano il lampadario
piuttosto che lo specchio una volta
abbiamo messo questo grafico davanti una
persona che governava un processo detto
mi sembra come di conto di guardare un
materiale guardarlo prima con l'occhio e
poi passare al microscopio per cento
nella struttura della materia in questo
caso entra nella struttura dei dati
le faccio un esempio che sta molto
simpatico ma lo racconta in modo adatto
a un ted è ora in una scuola e stavano
raccontando prima cosa sviluppiamo cosa
facciamo allora ma inutilmente di
raccontare un'esperienza della mia vita
personale ma che fosse tangibile anche a
loro
ok ragazzi facciamo finta che in questa
classe in questo momento passi un
ragazzo o una ragazza con i classici
cammini della bellezza tutti guardiamo
tutti ci giriamo e anche se passano
delle ore
se il nostro cervello gli vuole
riportare alla nostra lamentele
ricostruiamo bene proprio perché si basa
su quei canoni dominanti classici della
bellezza però ma sinceramente non mi
direbbe niente non più di tanto poi
casomai dopo passo una ragazza che
nessuna nota io rimango folgorato le
notti dopo non penso ad altro scrivo
lettere d'amore l'ascolto poesie le
struggenti ascolto musica deprimente e
penso lei innamorato perso ma nessuno
l'ha notata e lei non portava quelle
correlazioni forti però il suo charme il
suo charme queste correlazioni deboli
per il mio cervello per il mio modo di
essere
non ho totalmente colpito e mi
descrivono molto meglio e mi
rappresentano come entità fabio rispetto
a voi perché il suo modo di camminare
sono veri parlare di mettersi posto i
capelli sistema si gli occhiali mi hanno
colpito
ecco tutte queste correlazioni deboli
sono un patrimonio di informazione che
oltre a descrivere bene ma se venisse
grafica toe con un quadro di date messo
davanti alla persona che deve decidere
come gestire fabio avrebbe chiaro tutto
ora è molto più chiaro che a fabio sarei
una peculiarità quindi avrete le mie
caratteristiche e quindi sarebbe potrei
fare gli auguri ti predittivi sui miei
comportamenti capire con quali persone
potrà andare d'accordo meno ecco poi il
discorso è degenerato nella scuola però
rimanendo ai ice timida ed ecco lo
charme questa formazione debole ha
influito questi processi
oggi c'è di mettere includere le persone
nello sviluppo di intelligenza
artificiale piuttosto che di questa
analisi di grandi dati che non sempre
intelligenza artificiale
sicuramente è molto bello dire
intelligenza artificiale ma sono tanti
metodi efficaci e oggi lo applichiamo
nel marketing applicato nel trading
piuttosto che nei processi industriali
ma ogni tanto mi capita di pensare
quanto sarebbe interessante se applicato
anche nella politica
se un governo che prende una decisione o
attuare un piano politico avesse davanti
non solo le correlazioni forte di una
determinata scelta ma anche tutte le
correlazioni deboli si potrebbero
mettere anche i cittadini nelle
condizioni di comprendere meglio una
decisione da prendere
la politica tornerebbe ad essere
sensibile tornerebbe ad essere anche
inclusiva per tante persone che hanno un
approccio fresco il matematico
ecco tutto questo sviluppo è abbastanza
ancora alle prime armi ma è tutta la
vita che sogna di andare sul palco col
più floyd
quest'anno ha fatto quasi più per me e
noi siamo alle prime armi in questo
settore e quindi perché porti tim floyd
interesse per me una correlazione forte
e debole e rappresentano un po un gruppo
musicale che in una londra degli anni
settanta underground ha portato un nuovo
suono un suono prog rock prog hanno
iniziato a fondere gli strumenti
classici con gli strumenti elettronici
lavorano su sintetizzatore
sperimentavano sonorità nuove e la
sperimentazione all'inizio era un po
distonica e all'epoca c'era syd barrett
e fecero dei primi ad un incredibile e
sperimentavano sperimentavano fino a che
non hanno trovato una armonia che
potesse includere l'aspetto elettroni
con il rock prog col rock classico fino
ad arrivare a creare una the dark side
of the moon è un capolavoro oltre che
musicale anche di matematica perché sono
24 tracce sovrapposte e tanti aspetti
matematici nella gestione di questa
nuova concept album
ecco mi auguro che anche oggi ci sono
tanti syd barrett che sperimentino
dell'intelligenza artificiale con
l'obiettivo di arrivare a scrivere un
nuovo concept album che includa l'uomo
nello sviluppo di questa nuova
tecnologia che sarà sicuramente più
dirompente del rock prog e grazie
[Applauso]